هذا هو قلب إنتاج شركة بيونتك ،
وهو مفاعل حيوي ينتج
mrna لبنة بناء لقاح pfizer
biontech ،
لذلك بدأنا في كتابي
بتصنيع مادة الدواء ،
هذه عملية كيميائية حيوية
تحدث أساسًا في كل خلية ولكن
هنا
انتقلنا إلى  مفاعل حيوي
وهذا يستغرق يومًا واحدًا
أو يومين
تقريبًا ، فليسكا شيلينج هي رئيس
الإنتاج في مصنع بيونتك الجديد في
ماربورغ بألمانيا
، وقد حصل للتو على شهادة من
وكالة الأدوية الأوروبية وأخبرتني أن
فريق العمل يعمل بالفعل على
زيادة الإنتاج لدينا جميعًا
أصدقاء لنا  لديك عائلة لدينا
تعرف الكثير من الأشخاص
المتأثرين بهذا الوضع الوبائي
ونريد جميعًا الخروج لذلك نحن
سعداء جدًا لأننا نستطيع فعل شيء بنشاط
ضد الموقف الذي نعيشه في
المفاعل الحيوي الذي يتم تشغيله في
غرفة نظيفة خاصة  قد لا تبدو ضخمة ولكنها
يمكن أن
تنتج ما يكفي من mrna لحوالي ثمانية
ملايين جرعة
كل يومين تقول التكنولوجيا الحيوية أن الشركة
تأمل في إنتاج  مليار جرعة في
غضون عام
في هذا المصنع وحده لقاح مطلوب بشدة في
الوقت الحالي ، هناك طلب هائل على
اللقاحات ضد فيروس كورونا الجديد
أكثر بكثير من
المعروض في جميع أنحاء العالم ، ولهذا السبب من
المهم جدًا لنباتات مثل هذا
ألا تنهض فقط  الركض
ولكن للوقوف والجري
بأقصى سرعة ممكنة
بينما تقوم دول مثل الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
وإسرائيل بتطعيم سكانها
بسرعة
، يعاني الاتحاد الأوروبي ومعظم العالم
من نقص حاد في اللقاحات
على الرغم من حقيقة ذلك
لقد تجاوزت شركة far biontech و pfizer
كمية اللقاح التي
وعدت بتقديمها للشريك
المؤسس للشركة وأخبر CNN
أنهم
يحاولون باستمرار زيادة الإنتاج ،
فهذه تقنية جديدة
لا يمكنك فقط إعادة توظيف منشآت اللقاح
الموجودة هناك ولا يمكنك أيضًا
تدريب الأشخاص
بسرعة كبيرة  لذلك نحن نعمل ونقلب
كل حجر أساسًا
للارتقاء بقدراتنا
وإطلاقها وتأمل الشركة في ذلك  o
زيادة السرعة مع مواقع مثل هذه
الدخول في جولة بلاتكين فريد من نوعه
سي إن إن ماربورغ ألمانيا